Trascrizione: Emma Linford
Revisore: Alessandra Tadiotto
Questa che vedete alle mie spalle
è la rotonda di San Vittore.
Il cuore del carcere di Milano,
uno dei più grandi d'Italia.
2000 detenuti, uomini, donne,
anche bambini dagli zero ai tre anni.
Parto da questa rotonda perché
è il simbolo del carcere,
l'ho scelta come simbolo,
perché ovunque giri lo sguardo
hai solo sbarre e muri, muri e sbarre.
Non c'è nient'altro.
Si parla molto di carcere
in questi giorni,
ma senza sapere spesso veramente cos'é.
Il carcere è questo:
un luogo che ti taglia fuori
completamente,
fisicamente ed emotivamente.
Il carcere, io dico,
è una contraddizione in sé.
II carcere è un ossimoro,
perché è un luogo
dove si pensa di reinserire
escludendo le persone,
dove si pensa di responsabilizzare,
privando le persone
della possibilità di decidere.
Questa è 'la domandina'.
Si chiama così, domandina,
come se fossero dei bambini scemi.
La domandina è la regina del carcere,
un modulo pre-stampato
che tutti i detenuti,
ma proprio tutti devono compilare
per fare od ottenere qualsiasi cosa.
Per parlare con il direttore,
per andare in permesso,
per iscriversi a scuola, per andare
a trovare la madre che sta morendo
per frequentare la biblioteca.
Per fare qualsiasi cosa, si scrive
'Alla Signoria Vostra' e si chiede.
I detenuti chiedono e qualcun altro decide.
Ogni giorno migliaia di domandine
vengono compilate, mandate al direttore.
A volte si perdono nella strada di andata,
a volte in quella di ritorno.
Qualcuna arriva con un no,
qualcuna arriva con un sì.
La vita intera dei detenuti
passa per un modulo.
Il detenuto chiede, un altro decide.
Torno a San Vittore.
Prendo in prestito un video
fatto da un collega del TG2.
In carcere si vive chiusi,
chiusi fuori dal mondo.
Si vive in una normalità
che non ha niente di normale.
È una normalità fatta
di spazi chiusi, sovraffollati,
dove si vive insieme
chi fuma e chi non fuma,
dove si vive insieme chi fa il Ramadan
e chi si cucina gli spaghetti,
dove l'unica cosa importante da fare
è far scorrere il tempo.
Il tempo della pena.
Far passare il tempo.
Il più possibile.
Io entro in carcere da volontaria,
per mia fortuna, da ormai quasi 30 anni
e ho imparato a conoscerlo
attraverso le piccole cose,
non attraverso i grandi numeri,
i 20 000 di troppo che, ahimé, ci sono
ma nella sua quotidianità.
perché il carcere ti entra
nella pelle giorno per giorno,
attraverso le piccole cose,
inesorabilmente ti trasforma, ti cambia.
Ti rende disadatto, poi, a vivere fuori.
Ho conosciuto la solitudine
vissuta in mezzo alla gente
quando Marcello, un ragazzo,
avrà avuto meno di 30 anni,
mi è venuto incontro felice
con una cartolina in mano e mi ha detto:
"Con questa ci vado avanti un mese."
Ed è proprio così.
Con quella cartolina riescono
a tirare avanti un altro mese.
Ho conosciuto la spersonalizzazione
profonda del carcere
quando ho salutato un ragazzo,
gli ho detto: "Ciao, Salvatore."
Lui si è bloccato, mi ha guardato,
ho pensato: "Cosa ho detto?"
Poi mi ha guardato e mi ha detto:
"Ma tu ti ricordi il mio nome."
Come dire 'non sono uno dei tanti,
uno uguale a tutti gli altri'.
Ho conosciuto la difficoltà
di parlare e di farsi ascoltare
quando Pasquale si era tagliato
di nuovo le braccia.
È l'autolesionismo.
E allora gli ho detto:
"Ma perché, Pasquale?"
Lui mi ha fatto vedere
tutte le cicatrici che aveva
e dice: "Vedi, per ogni taglio
ho avuto una risposta."
Ho conosciuto la spersonalizzazione
anche quando Ubaldo mi ha detto:
"Daniela, la nostra identità, noi la lasciamo
insieme alle impronte digitali,
quando entriamo in carcere."
Ecco, giorno dopo giorno
il carcere ti entra nella pelle.
Ti cambia, ti trasforma.
Ti costringe ad adattarti a un mondo
che non ha niente di normale.
Con l'associazione VIC,
questo è il logo della mia associazione,
siamo 100 volontari e andiamo
nelle carceri romane di Rebibbia.
Sono 4 carceri, 2000 tra uomini e donne.
Ascoltiamo le persone, le incontriamo.
Abbiamo una casa alloggio,
una cooperativa di lavoro.
Cerchiamo di incontrare persone
in questo mondo dove si vive
in 14 in 32 m quadri
per 22 ore al giorno.
E incontriamo persone
che hanno bisogno di tutto,
dalla libertà, in primo luogo,
ma poi hanno bisogno dei vestiti.
Di una casa, di un lavoro
per chi sta per uscire.
Di ristabilire rapporti.
Di avere un permesso di soggiorno
per gli stranieri.
Di ritrovare se stessi, un po' tutti.
Ai nostri volontari noi lo diciamo sempre:
"Ricordatevi che non risolverete nulla.
I problemi che vi verranno incontro
quando parlerete con queste persone
sono troppo grossi perché riusciate
a dare delle risposte."
Però possiamo fare molto.
Possiamo - rubo - portare gocce di vita,
possiamo portare,
come questo pupazzetto
attaccato alle sbarre di una cella,
un po' di vita, quella normale,
quella libera che scorre fuori.
Quella che conosciamo tutti noi.
Possiamo portare
un po' di sapore della vita.
Possiamo, soprattutto, esserci.
Possiamo esserci per loro, anzi,
possiamo esserci per loro e con loro
e per ognuno di loro e con ognuno di loro.
Con il suo nome, con la sua faccia,
con la sua storia, con la sua vita.
Come Salvatore, solo con Salvatore,
non con un detenuto.
In un luogo come il carcere,
così deprivato di tutto,
è un po' come stare nel deserto:
una goccia di acqua è preziosissima.
Una goccia di vita è preziosissima.
E allora quello che sembra inutile,
a volte, in carcere lavora silenzioso.
Anche lì, inesorabile.
Queste gocce vanno nel profondo.
E allora vi racconterò alcune cose inutili
che abbiamo fatto in carcere.
Comincio con un'iniziativa
che sembrava folle anche a me.
Nel 2006, c'era appena stato l'indulto,
c'erano un po' meno detenuti
e abbiamo provato a proporre,
insieme a Paco Lanciano,
che è un astrofisico,
una notte a guardare le stelle
nel carcere.
Abbiamo approfittato
del temporaneo svuotamento
e tutti insieme, sdraiati 'nell'aria',
nel cortile dove si trascorre l'ora d'aria,
eravamo sdraiati a guardare le stelle.
Dal direttore all'ergastolano
eravamo tutti insieme.
Io avevo molto chiaro una cosa:
che queste persone passavano
dal chiuso della cella
da questa cella
dove non respiri,
dove non riesci neanche
a stare in piedi tutti insieme,
(bisogna fare a turni
perché non c'è posto)
all'infinito dell'universo.
E questa cosa mi piaceva molto.
E abbiamo iniziato questo viaggio,
tutti sdraiati a pancia all'aria
e Paco Lanciano ci ha raccontato
della Stella Polare, dei viaggiatori,
dei navigatori, di come si orientavano.
Un detenuto che navigava
trasportando cose più o meno lecite
ci ha raccontato lui come
si orientava con le stelle.
Un detenuto senegalese ci ha detto:
"Ma io vedo un altro cielo." Sì, è vero.
Abbiamo parlato dei miti che ci aiutano
a ritrovare le stelle.
Dei telescopi di Galileo, l'oroscopo,
qualcuno faceva domande
e andavamo avanti.
Avevo chiaro la dimensione dello spazio,
quello che non avevo pensato
era la dimensione del tempo.
In carcere il tempo che domina la vita
è un tempo lineare.
Da oggi al fine pena.
Esiste solo questo, un filo
che mi porta al fine pena.
Ma questo solo per chi ha il fine pena.
Gli ergastolani che vengono
chiamati 'Fine-pena-mai'
hanno oggi e poi domani
e poi ancora domani
e così fino alla fine.
Non avevo pensato
che nell'Universo
gli astrofisici hanno
un'altra idea del tempo
e allora, quando Paco Lanciano
ci ha spiegato degli anni luce
e che quella stella che ci ha indicato
noi vedevamo come era 1 500 anni fa
c'è stato un mormorio tra le persone.
Uno si è alzato e ha detto:
"Dio non esiste".
Non capivano più niente,
è stato un momento molto forte.
Alla fine qualcuno gli ha chiesto:
"Ma come nasce l'Universo?"
E allora Lanciano ci ha spiegato
che nasce dalle stelle,
dalla polvere di stelle,
che anche la vita nasce dalle stelle
e che in fondo
ognuno di noi, ognuno di loro,
ognuno di noi tutti insieme
siamo figli delle stelle,
tutti, nessuno escluso.
E poi i figli delle stelle
in parte sono tornati in cella,
in parte siamo usciti.
La storia non finisce qui
perché il giorno dopo mi ha chiamato
una volontaria del femminile
e mi ha detto: "Daniela,
una donna del carcere mi ha detto
che voi avete fatto questa iniziativa."
Perché 'Radio Carcere' funziona
un po' più veloce dei social network.
E io gli ho detto "Sì, è vero"
E una donna gli ha detto:
"Per favore, fatelo anche da noi.
Perché io da 7 anni non vedo il cielo."
Questa donna vive in una cella
che ha le finestre a bocca di lupo.
Non vedeva da 7 anni la luna e le stelle.
L'anno dopo, i tempi del carcere
sono tempi molto lunghi,
siamo riusciti a fare una notte
a guardare le stelle anche al femminile.
Quella donna era ancora lì e si è riempita
gli occhi di quelle stelle e della luna
che per noi sono così normali.
E questa è una delle prime cose inutili.
Mi chiedo che cosa abbiamo fatto.
Credo molto.
Abbiamo fatto un'altra iniziativa
molto diversa.
Ho parlato con Vittorio Sermonti,
un intellettuale, un esperto
di Dante e dell'Eneide.
Lui andava in giro per l'Italia
a leggere l'Eneide.
Gli ho chiesto se veniva anche da noi.
A Rebibbia.
Abbiamo parlato a lungo,
cosa facciamo cosa non facciamo:
"Leggiamo Dante? Leggiamo l'Eneide?
Leggiamo Pinocchio?"
Alla fine mi ha detto: "Ma se io faccio
una lezione sulla poesia, che dici?"
Io gli ho detto: "Mi piace."
Perché in carcere ci sono
due generi letterari:
le lettere, si scrive e si riceve molto -
è uno dei pochi posti dove ancora
si scrive con carta e penna,
le lettere vanno avanti e vanno indietro,
sono il filo con il mondo,
con gli affetti e con gli amici -
e poi le poesie. Sono tutti poeti.
Gli unici libri che scompaiono
dalle biblioteche del carcere
sono i libri di poesia.
E allora ci ha fatto una lezione.
Come nasce una poesia,
ha spiegato le rime
con le onde, con la risacca.
Poi ha letto una poesia di Leopardi,
"L'Infinito".
Ma prima di leggere la versione
che conosciamo tutti,
ha letto due versioni intermedie
che hanno ritrovato,
perché ci ha spiegato
come nasce una poesia,
come si lavora sulle parole,
come si crea.
E poi mi ha chiesto:
"Daniela, dammi
una poesia di Pasquale."
Pasquale era quel ragazzo
di cui vi ho raccontato,
che si era tagliato le braccia.
Pasquale era un detenuto in quel carcere.
In quei giorni non era lì
perché l'avevano trasferito in un OPG,
un 'Ospedale Psichiatrico Giudiziario' -
gli ex-manicomi criminali.
Mi ha detto: "Dammi quella poesia,
perché Pasquale spiega bene
con i suoi versi come nasce una poesia."
E ha letto la poesia di Pasquale.
Pasquale parla con il foglio di carta
e gli dice: "Foglio,
tu non sai cosa diventerai
quando io scriverò su di te.
Non sai come ti trasformerai."
E l'ha letta con la stessa dignità
con cui aveva letto le poesie di Leopardi
e con cui dopo ha letto Dante Alighieri.
È stato un momento importante.
Lì tutti sapevano chi era Pasquale,
come tutti sapevano chi era Leopardi.
Un seme di libertà, è stato.
(Voce rotta) Scusate.
Questi sono gli incontri.
Nelle foto vediamo Vittorio Sermonti.
Io non so se stia leggendo
Leopardi, se stia leggendo Dante,
o se stia leggendo Pasquale.
Perché tutti e tre avevano pari dignità.
Tutti e tre i figli delle stelle
avevano pari dignità.
E poi c'è un'altra cosa.
Anche qui prendo in prestito un video.
Vi parlerò del teatro in carcere.
Anzi, non vi parlerò
del teatro in carcere,
vi parlerò di Salvatore Striano,
è questa persona.
Salvatore è stato a lungo
un detenuto in carcere.
In carcere ha incontrato il teatro.
Qui lo vediamo.
Lui ha partecipato anche al film
dei fratelli Taviani 'Cesare deve morire',
che racconta proprio dell'attività
di teatro in carcere.
E adesso Salvatore è uscito.
Salvatore stava nel reparto
di alta sicurezza
per criminalità organizzata.
Era un delinquente serio.
Lui adesso è uscito dalla galera
e fa l'attore; lo fa per professione.
Ha partecipato al film 'Gomorra',
ha partecipato a serie televisive.
Di solito gli fanno fare il delinquente,
ma sa fare anche altre parti.
Io un giorno l'ho incontrato a teatro,
gli ho detto: "Salvatore" -
tutti lo chiamano Sasà, in realtà -
dico, "Sasà, a cosa serve
il teatro in carcere?"
E lui mi ha detto:
"Guarda, io non lo so,
ti posso dire a cosa è servito a me."
Ho detto: "Va bene, dimmi."
Lui mi ha detto: "Sai, io sono napoletano,
sono nato in uno di questi quartieri
dove quando nasci sai già
quale sarà il tuo destino.
Io il mio destino l'ho seguito.
Ho fatto il percorso criminale,
sono arrivato in carcere
con il mio curriculum pesante.
In carcere ho incontrato il teatro.
Ho dovuto imparare a entrare nei ruoli,
nelle parti, nelle vite degli altri.
A furia di entrare nelle vite degli altri,
e di entrare negli altri ruoli,
ho capito una cosa:
che potevo scegliere
il mio ruolo nella vita."
E lo ha fatto.
Oggi, dopo una lunghissima
vita di carcere, dentro e fuori,
Sasà è cambiato.
Per lui il teatro in carcere -
e io sono convinta solo per lui,
forse nessun altro farà
un percorso uguale al suo delle migliaia
di detenuti che lavorano in carcere -
per lui il teatro è stato quella goccia
che ha incontrato il seme
che era pronto a germogliare.
È nato un altro Sasà.
È nato Sasà l'attore.
Oggi, Sasà continua ad andare in carcere,
ma ci va per incontrare gli altri detenuti,
per raccontare, per testimoniare
che si può cambiare.
Che lui ce l'ha fatta
e che lui era esattamente come loro.
Sono alcuni semi.
In carcere si fanno molte cose.
Ognuna di queste è una goccia di vita.
Ognuna di queste gocce
può incontrare il seme di libertà
e può servire a far crescere
la pianta di questo seme.
Grazie.